among us  [Music]  a question for both um is this the best  way of  deciding a world champion or could it be  other ways of doing it like  for example the fifa world cup way or  as an ordinary chess tournament or  whatever  yeah  well it's hard to say because  i believe  their  importance of traditions and chess  is  really big and  i guess  whatever works you shouldn't like try to  to make it work better yeah i mean in  order not to break it so i believe this  system with them matches is more or less  fair  uh but  i mean of course it has some obvious  drawbacks because it's like not  being played yearly and and so on but  i mean uh well it's you know we can  discuss it like  the whole night  magnus um  there's uh there's a saying that  if you don't have anything nice to say  you shouldn't say anything at all so i'm  going to invoke that particular  saying right here